here's a little tip of why this makes
you so much more money for no more work
you make far more money because of how
much more valuable they are not because
of how much more valuable you are but if
you sell to a more qualified customer
you in a very real way can make them
more money for the same work so if I did
cro so conversion rate optimization for
an e-commerce business that was doing a
million dollars a year and I added 10
they would go from one million dollars a
year to 1.1 million dollars a year now
if I did that same work at a business
that's doing a hundred million dollars a
year they would go from 100 million to
110 million so same work I made a
hundred thousand dollars of value here I
made 10 million dollars of value here
who do you think I can charge more this
guy which one was more work neither they
were the same work but I get a hundred
times the output so it wasn't because of
us it's because of them and so if we
pick the right customers we're able to
charge significantly more and it's
because we really are in a real way
providing more value